[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants bon mon le cheval et
tu es bien pressé ce soir nounours j'ai
soif patron ne bois pas trop d'eau
compte rien à craindre je n'aime pas ça
oh non je ne vais pas boire d'eau je
vais m'offrir un petit cocktail maison
je ne vous dis que ça ne te rend surtout
pas malade nounours nersac sont
infaillibles patron et hop hop hop hop
hop
bonsoir maison ou là ce qu'il fait chaud
chez vous ce soir
que diriez vous d'un bon petit cocktail
pour nous désaltérer un peu mon chenard
succulent oui on vient on va le préparer
la cuisine quand quelques kilos
[Musique]
e
wallon face au punch ou risible j'y vois
la coke terre love lust love joe beef
résonne l'hymne le temps papillon voilà
cocktail aux raisins verts aucune
importance un peu de recueil mots les
sommes en jeu ne jamais employé devrait
raisin les raisins aux matières
plastiques étant de qualité très
supérieure
ils font les choisir noir
antoine droit d'odeurs ceresa ajouter
quelques coquilles d'oeuf bien blanches
dans la poubelle
mais voilà ajouté une petite corne est
blanche je sais quoi internet
je ne sais pas aucune importance a
ajouté un brin de n'importe quoi arroser
de vinaigre 11 copieusement voilà est
maintenant passé le tout à la moulinette
avec avec recueillement
la messine merci
alors on met tous dans la moulinette
dispose sable le shérif avec précaution
une explosion on est en a exclu l
hécatombe à terre attention français
dont la retourne la moulinette tout bête
cet enfant star ne restez pas trop près
les enfants ça va jaillir je tourne je
trouve que j'ai soif mois vous avez
raison ou non
j'en ai attrapé ma peugeot c'est
meilleur
[Musique]
non
tiens un gros paquet de bonbons au miel
ça te fera du bien
merci les enfants que c'est bon il faut
que je me chauffe
non allez vite vous coucher tout seul au
revoir
ce sont ces bonbons obama
[Musique]
oui
oh
[Musique]
alors mon cher nounours ils étaient
réussite en cocktail aux ja patron ça
n'a rien donné
et pourtant il y avait tout ce qu'il
fallait pour faire quelque chose de bon
seul bonbons sont succulents où l'on
voulait pas pas trop non merci ne nous
fais attention si tu en manges trop tu
vas avoir mal aux dents meudon ce que ce
boom bonne nuit des enfants à demain
paul ii
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
[Musique]